[Musique]
histoire de madame la copie
ouais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui troisième épisode
le soleil
[Musique]
de santé
et
[Musique]
c
je ne
m
[Musique]
et
nous voici revenu au poulailler au tout
est changé
[Musique]
le jeune coq a pris de l'assurance et se
pavane au milieu des poules admiratif
[Musique]
le vieux coq délaissé est tout triste
dans un coin et la contraire bonjour
madame pic me voulez vous vous en faites
une tête ya de quoi regardez comme on me
traite et pourtant c'est moi qui fais
tout ici l'ordre la discipline c'est moi
qui réveille la ferme
le nouveau lui se lève un quart d'heure
après tout le monde et si on attendait
après lui pour réveiller le fermier
qu'elle ça mais si dur mais on pourrait
toujours à temps plein alors dit calme
ce matin on a entendu le fermier et dire
que les cousins est arrivé c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle non plus tôt et
pourtant vous étiez si fier d'être un
jour kakovin comme votre père t'a
glorieux sort non oui c'est un glorieux
sort quand il est très lointain mais moi
je me sens si genou co alors que faire
fumer est bien c'est une idée venez avec
moi dans la forêt
[Musique]
ce bruit qui fait fuir madame puces et
suzy qui apporte du grain en poule mais
elle a perdu quelque chose
[Musique]
les
mais le fermier très en colère alors
oula tu perds du temps bracelet aussi
beau bracelet en or ou presque au nord
sais tu pas malheureux pendant que le
fermier grands de sa fille rebelle bruno
rentrer deschamps
notre vieux coq qui surveille de la mare
aux canards ce qui se passe se cache
vite guettant la première occasion de
s'enfuir dans la forme et le fermier
crie toujours alors c'est qu'on a volé
il faut savoir qui
[Musique]
c
oui il
[Musique]